[Musik]
mindestens
2500 Menschen sind im türkisch-syrischen
Grenzgebiet ums Leben gekommen unzählige
sind noch immer unter den Trümmern
verschüttet das Erdbeben traf die Region
gegen 4 Uhr 17 Ortszeit in der Nacht mit
der Stärke 7,7 wenige Stunden später das
zweite große Beben in der Türkei und
auch in Syrien läuft die Suche nach den
Überlebenden
herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf-spezial
wieso verschiebt sich um circa zehn
Minuten
das Erdbeben hat viele Menschen mitten
im Schlaf überrascht es war so stark
dass die Ausläufer noch bis nach Ägypten
zu spüren waren jetzt verschärfen Kälte
Regen und Schnee die aktuelle Notlage
noch weiter
betroffen ist das Grenzgebiet zwischen
der Türkei und Syrien vor allem um die
türkische Grenzstadt Gaziantep über die
Lage im Katastrophengebiet Bernd
einen roten Schutzhelm haben sie ihr
schon aufgesetzt jetzt befreien sie ganz
vorsichtig die junge Frau die im
südostanatolischen diakerbakira zwischen
drömern feststeckte ein seltener
Glücksmoment an diesem furchtbaren Tag
es war noch zu nachtschlafender Zeit als
die Erde heftig bebte im syrischen afrin
hält ein Bewohner mit dem Handy die
zerstörerischen Augenblicke fest
hunderte Häuser stürzen sofort ein
begraben die Bewohner unter sich etliche
Gebäude werden so schwer beschädigt dass
sie bei Nachbeben einstürzen
mit bloßen Händen versuchen Helfer zu
den Verschütteten vorzudringen
tonnenschwere Trümmer müssen beiseite
geräumt werden um die unzähligen Opfer
wie hier in Adana zu bergen
mein Enkel ist 18 Monate alt bitte
helfen Sie ihm wir bekommen keine
Nachrichten von ihnen sie haben im
zwölften Stock gewohnt
dann um die Mittagszeit ein türkisches
Kamerateam ist gerade in Malatya
unterwegs erneut schwere Erdstöße
wieder stürzen Häuser ein überall im
Südosten der Türkei und im nördlichen
Syrien wo schon der Krieg so viel Leid
und notbrachte
die Kliniken völlig überlastet ständig
bringen Rettungskräfte verletzte
Menschen doch allen können Sie so
schnell gar nicht helfen
ich habe vier Kinder und meine Frau wir
haben friedlich zu Hause geschlafen dann
haben wir das Beben gespürt und sind
sofort aufgewacht weil es so stark war
stündlich steigt die Zahl der Opfer
erste Rettungskräfte aus aller Welt sind
bereits unterwegs doch die Türkei und
Syrien werden noch so viel mehr Hilfe
brauchen
und in der Katastrophenregion in
Gaziantep spreche ich jetzt mit Kemal
bural Tarlan er arbeitet für eine
türkische Kulturorganisation guten Abend
wir haben Sie denn selbst das Erdbeben
erlebt
werden
wir haben erstmal abgewartet als die
Beben nicht aufhörten und als es auch
immer stärker wurde
da war das wie ein Schock
meine Frau war in Panik noch stärker als
ich und wir haben erst geschaut ganz
schnell geschaut wo wir uns innerhalb
der Wohnung
verkriechen können wo wir uns
unterstellen können das brachte nicht
sehr viel so haben wir uns sehr rasch
angekleidet
und dann als sie auf die Straße gingen
wie war dann die Situation vor Ort
als sie auf die Straße gingen waren alle
unsere Nachbarn alle im Stadtteil
bereits dabei auf die Straße zu strömen
die Menschen waren in Panik und die
Kinder die Babys Erwachsene alte
Menschen alle alle diejenigen die eben
in den Häusern waren sie hatten das
Nötigste mitgenommen eingewickelt es
schneite sehr stark denn seit drei Tagen
das muss man wissen ist die Region
Gaziantep und da starken Schneefall ihre
Frau ist der erste wie sieht es denn mit
der medizinischen Versorgung aus
heute ist wirklich eine Schocksituation
für alle sehr viele verletzte Menschen
die Verletzten werden ins Krankenhaus
gebracht es stürzen weiter Gebäude ein
und darum kann man auch sagen das wird
so gesagt dass nicht ausreichend Ärzte
vorhanden sind wir haben nicht genug
Ärzte denn es arbeiten ja schon seit dem
frühen Morgen immer die gleichen Ärzte
meine Frau die ja Ärztin ist ist heute
auf freiwilliger Basis in einer
Poliklinik tätig und nach dem ersten
schocktag
da kann man dann besser eine
Bestandsaufnahme davon machen was
gebraucht wird welches medizinische
Material und welche Vorrichtungen aber
da weiterhin Gebäude einstürzen in
diesem Gebäuden befinden sich auch
Menschen und so ist man damit
beschäftigt die Menschen zu retten sie
ins Krankenhaus zu verbringen dort Erste
Hilfe ärztliche Notversorgung zu leisten
und deswegen kann ich hier noch keine
endgültigen Aussagen machen ja vielen
Dank für diese erschütternden Eindrücke
und alles Gute für Sie
ich danke herzlichen Dank und auf
Wiedersehen
ja das Erdbeben heute war besonders
heftig für die Türkei aber nicht das
erste immer wieder ist der Region von
schweren Erdbeben betroffen mehrere
Kontinentalplatten Grenzen dort
aneinander über das Leben mit der Gefahr
Jan fritzsche
[Musik]
es sind Bilder die erschreckend an die
von heute erinnern
immer wieder wird die Türkei im Laufe
ihrer Geschichte von schweren Erdbeben
erschüttert
beim tödlichsten des 20 Jahrhunderts im
Jahr 1939 sterben 33.000 Menschen ein
ähnliches riesenbeben auch 1999
17.000 Menschen kommen ums Leben mehr
als 100.000 Familien werden obdachlos
zahlen die befürchten lassen dass auch
dieses Mal die Zahl der Toten noch stark
steigen könnte doch warum ist die Türkei
so anfällig für Erdbeben wie kaum ein
anderes Land
der Grund ist die geografische Lage am
Rand gleich mehrerer Erdplatten die in
unterschiedliche Richtungen drücken
so schiebt die arabische Platte die
anatolische Platte seit langem nach
Westen zweieinhalb Zentimeter im Jahr an
deren Grenze liegt das Epizentrum des
jetzigen Lebens ab
und zu von diesem plat
ten wenn sie sich
Bewegung nicht abgebaut sondern es baut
sich Spannung auf und die entlädt sich
so wie wir das jetzt sehen in einem sehr
starken Ereignis
langfristig beobachten Wissenschaftler
noch etwas wegen des Drucks der
arabischen Platte wandern die Beben an
der oberen Plattengrenze in der Türkei
immer weiter nach Westen experten warnen
als nächstes könnte es Istanbul treffen
welche Folgen das für die 15 Millionen
Metropole hätte lässt sich kaum absehen
schätzungen gehen von bis zu 100.000
Toten aus sicher ist das nächste
Erdbeben in der Türkei ist keine Frage
des ob sondern eine des wann
dann schauen wir auf die
Hilfsorganisationen noch mal in die
besonders betroffene türkische
Grenzstadt Gaziantep dort ist Jesko
Weikert von der betthungerhilfe guten
Abend wie erleben Sie diese Katastrophe
vor Ort
ja ist das ist sehr schlimm wir haben
also ging ja heute morgen los um 4 Uhr
hat es nach meinem Empfinden eine Minute
lang gewackelt wie blöd wie wenn man auf
dem Güterwagen drauf steht
und seitdem ja die Leute sind aber zum
Haus raus gerannt
und ja es hat seitdem ein Haufen
Nachbeben gegeben das heißt die Leute
sind oder die Menschen sind zum Teil in
Autos draußen zum Teil in Cafés
zum Teil sitzen die in so ähm
Bushaltestellen und trauen sich einfach
nicht mehr in ihre Wohnung rein wer ist
denn Hilfe inzwischen schon angekommen
oder wie müssen wir uns ganz konkret die
Situation vor Ort vorstellen
die Türkei hat ihre also hat eine sehr
gute Nothilfe Struktur der türkische
Rote Halbmond ist sehr gut die haben so
eine Art
thw-abfahrt die auch Nothilfe leisten
können die haben sofort angefangen das
ist nur so also die
türkischen Behörden sprechen von der
größten Katastrophe seit 1939
das hat in der Türkei die Zahlen die ich
jetzt habe sind irgendwie anderthalb
Tausend tote schon bisher gegeben das
werden vermutlich noch eine Runde mehr
werden aber das ist einfach so ein
großer Katastrophe das wird dauern das
wird auch dauern bis das behoben ist
also die ganze hat Millionen Einwohner
und Sie müssen sich vorstellen das sind
lauter also Apartmentgebäude Tritte drei
Stück Werke viel Stockwerke fünf
Stockwerke die haben die Leute Heizen
mit Gas sie können sich vorstellen was
das für ein Aufwand ist einfach nur
sicherzustellen dass diese Gebäude nicht
zusammenfallen
zu gucken dass keine ist keine
Gasexplosionen gibt also das wird alles
noch
sich sehr sehr lange hinziehen also das
wirklich ich habe sowas noch nie erlebt
das ist wirklich wünsche ich niemanden
sowas mitzubekommen dann haben die
Erdbeben meine Gegend getroffen in der
sich viele Flüchtlinge aus Syrien
aufhalten was bedeutet diese Katastrophe
für die Region und was wissen Sie über
die Lage auf der syrischen Seite
wenn man sich anguckt Syrien da ist seit
zwölf Jahren Bürgerkrieg eine halbe
Million Leute sind umgekommen die Hälfte
von den Leuten in diesem Land sind
entweder binnenvertrieben oder leben
nicht mehr im Land ja
die haben genug ja dann haben sie im
Moment einen total fürchterlichen Winter
hier ja es ist irgendwie 1 2 3 Grad kalt
hier liegt überall Schnee ja die Straßen
sind in Syrien können sich vorstellen
ist die Infrastruktur hinüber da
die Leute haben genug und jetzt kriegen
sie noch so ein Erdbeben wo halt auch
die Gebäude sind
marode durch den Krieg sind nicht gut
gewartet und die ja brechen jetzt auch
noch zusammen ja das heißt das ist vom
Leid her kaum vorstellbar ja vielen Dank
Jesko Weickert und alles Gute für ihre
Arbeit und ich hoffe Ihr Dach über dem
Kopf ist sicher
vielen Dank
die Gespräche in die Türkei haben wir
aus leitungsgründen und der unsicheren
Lage aufgezeichnet ja wir haben es
gehört viel Hilfe ist nötig wenn sie die
Menschen in Syrien und der Türkei
unterstützen wollen können Sie spenden
beim Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien
iban.de 651
das war unser zdf-spezial mehr Infos
über die dramatische Lage im
Erdbebengebiet dann später im heute
journal oder jederzeit in der ZDF heute
App hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Markus
niabes und wieso auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]